told by the food industry that breakfast  is the most important meal of the day  but i think that's really just a was  meant just to sell cereal there was a  paper that came out that looked at the  conflicts of interests among people  who were invited to contribute to the  2020 dietary guidelines for americans  the experts get together right yeah yeah  like the food pyramid the usda mi plate  every five years so  in 2020  95 of the committee members  had conflicts of interest with pharma  with the food industry yeah who suffers  from that certainly not them it's like  the american people who just continue to  get more and more confused right being  steered more and more away from  ancestral foods like beef eggs fish  things like that right liver liver organ  meats yeah and towards these these high  margin  low protein ultra processed equivalents  of like human pet food essentially  that's what the standard american diet  really is now comprised of